[Music]
two
welcome welcome it's the leftovers
that's right we're back yeah hassan got
some complaints
last week they didn't drop a less right
yeah i heard that some people thought i
was saying let's let's ride
oh what no i'm just saying that's right
let's ride let's ride
i guess i guess
but that's good because today we're
talking about alex jones oh yeah my
favorite so there's some cot alex jones
memes it's nice to see him back
we are here from the three million
dollar bunker of course with newly
installed sam systems surface-to-air
missiles we have some kind of laser
um security systems like it
automatically targets poor people that
walk
in in between it like when they walk
through it's like oh it figures out what
your what your income is and your
network it analyzes like the thread
count of your pants
oh yeah
yeah they get immediately vaporized
thank you today
to our sponsors harry's honey and
stamps.com we got a special episode
today because next week is thanksgiving
we will be off next week
for the holidays but we want to arm you
guys to the teeth
um not just with surface-to-air missiles
but with uh
knowledge
it's still it's old what happened guys
what's he doing he's doing some nfd [ __ ]
right he's got uh [ __ ] of course ty
lopez is doing an nft he's got to be in
my garage yeah so ty lopez he fell off
kind of hard oh yeah i think he's he
bought this is so weird plus ratio
he bought plus ratio
he bought like one of these going
bankrupt during the pandemic chains like
marshalls or something no or what it was
one of these so yeah you're right yeah
google that dan yeah they got pier one
pier one he bought pier one and he's
like dude
i get to have stores imagine brick and
mortar stores all over the country he
bought pier one for like 30 million
dollars and that's the last started from
i don't know why the [ __ ] you did that
how can a guy who made like
he made who made his like
bread and butter on the internet turn
around and be like brick and mortar is
the future
what i think that was a horrible
investment that he's probably regretting
it's like purchasing buggies right
before ford motors like figures it out
you know these buggies they're going to
be fire next year
here
this is just from gosh what to say
yesterday yeah i'm blessing 20 people
with 10 000 in bitcoin in the next 24
hours 20 winners get 500 each
there's a total of our fees [ __ ]
posts
to enter all you have to do is follow
and retweet like my comments uh
um you know subscribe to my get rich
quick scheme
follow me on instagram follow me on tick
tock
i believe crypto will give wealth to the
people not just make us rich guys richer
yeah okay first of all is he even a rich
guy still
it's always
ever been like a real rich guy it's
always been a mystery to me how much
money this guy's worth or what i'm he
has a pretty prolific like
e
e commerce business i think he's but
it's all super shady like schemey stuff
i mean his entire i remember like back
when people were doing deep dives in the
tai lopez i remember looking into it a
little bit and it was all about like
getting young people to be able to dupe
like old people
that have like small businesses like he
would just teach you how to like scam
old people like restaurants which is a
huge business yeah you know yeah oh yeah
they do digital marketing for you know
your mom and pop shop and you know you
just don't really need to do anything
well he's one of these guys that gets
rich teaching people how to get rich
yeah which is a weird irony yeah i've
always said like look are you are you
gonna teach me how you're scamming me
right now is that like are you because
otherwise like that's not how you made
your money you didn't make your money
doing ads you made your money by telling
people like uh you know the
entrepreneurs of the world how they're
gonna get rich yeah the final step of
his
of his uh seminar should be and starting
your own get rich seminar yeah the only
the only person um
that is like that at least has like some
legitimacy
like that has done some work is uh i
would say garyvee and a lot of people
are ripping i'm an anti-garyvee no no i
bro have you seen his nfts we ripped
into him so [ __ ] hard
of course
of course i'm just saying he's better
than tyler in a field yeah but in a
field of like scammers he's the one
scammer that at least has like
you know it has some some
uh experience i'll agree with that
outside of just in the land of the blind
the one-eyed v is king oh yeah for sure
yeah i'll agree with that
he's managed to like market himself as
someone who
who is a serious person which surprised
me but he's like yeah he he's done the
typical like angel investor scam scammer
guy he's like a big
vc angel investor type
um and i i think all of that is a scam
as well but at least like that's
different scam investing angel investing
um it's gambling uh for the most part
it's just like you go and you wait for a
wave why is that a scam it's not a scam
i'm just saying like presenting yourself
as someone who's like a successful angel
investor that knows what they're doing
because they're looking at the
fundamentals is oftentimes the scammier
part of this because you're literally
pumping
10k to 50k to 60k
to these startups non-stop
you're funneling cash for a
decent chunk of equity
uh in a lot of these companies with the
hope that one becomes a whale yeah and
when you hit one whale it doesn't matter
and if you have capital you can do that
permanently you're saying there these
guys have this mystique like there's
these incredible businessmen but it's
not that they're just yeah i have money
and it's easy to put money
yeah yeah i agree with you there i don't
think it's anything slick to be a quote
angel investor by the way we found this
last year talking about gary you saw
this you know about this i do know about
this
are you serious well we thought this was
such an underground find okay well how
did you know about this i think i know
about this because of the show okay i
saw it and also because i tracked
closely uh you know
people that kiss their fathers on the
list you think i'm joking i'm not joking
bill belichick kisses his adult daughter
on the lips tom brady tom brady father
and his sons on the lips that one i like
the time i'm a firm believer that white
people get a lot of power from kissing
their parents on the lips that's just
the tom brady one was pretty interesting
to me like that that one was a little
disturbing and i love uh you know i love
my ch my son
um
but
like and and i don't get it and by the
way like pecking your parents on the i'm
not one for it personally but like i
don't have a problem with pecking your
parents on the lips tom brady is like he
made out with his son yeah he's like get
back here yeah
he's like yo yo where are you going i
didn't oh stop that's just get that off
the screen no it's just like that's not
even no i think that's not even i'm
serious take that off i'm just saying
that kid gonna be an incredible
quarterback one day
like it's just like that's where he's
getting his power from it's the secret
that they don't want you to know
yeah
put some tongue in there
here's garyvee anyway also powerful i
mean he this is how he made let's watch
the clip this is how he made his
father's three million dollar wine
company into a 60 million dollar wine
company okay
by kissing by tongue kissing him wait he
made out with his dad after someone said
should i focus on youtube or facebook
right
yeah and that's uh yeah
all right
all right let's go let's go it's so much
lip and even a little wait what the [ __ ]
wait wait what prompted that
uh pure love for for for your father
what else come here daddy
all right what's up all right let's go
let's go
yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy and it's like kind of open
mouth
yeah that's i mean that's nowhere near
on the tom brady scale that's like well
pull up the tom brady one since we're
doing tom brady would be like tom brady
would be like let's do that again let's
run that back but the tom brady one was
i didn't i didn't feel anything in that
one
the thing about tom brady's too is that
like not only did he say yo son get in
here and give me a kiss on the lips
before you do that
it was on camera
yeah so i'm assuming it's just like a
full tongue getting everything off
camera
i just i don't want to know
that was like a peck the second kiss
shared by father and son prompted tweets
from viewers using words like very
disturbing and uncomfortable
yeah yeah
he says that was just a pet come back
here and give me a
deeper kiss
give me a good one
yeah it's a lot
it's just like that's why you don't you
don't have what it takes to to be a
varsity athlete okay i'll just say it
i'm gonna have kids i'm gonna kiss him
all the time come here
the thought of that and again my son is
you know two and a half and
i'm just not in the business of kissing
him on the mountain you better not very
affectionately if you want if you want
him if you want him to start you know
playing basketball or football or
anything you better be a comedian
he will become a comedian if you kiss
him in the mouth a lot when he's a child
yeah [ __ ] him up good yeah exactly
by the way did i thank our sponsors you
did i think yes you did okay thank you
to them so today we as we were saying
before we went down the dad's making out
with their sons rabbit hole
that next week is thanksgiving and we're
thinking here on the leftovers it's all
about you know uh war it's all-out war
here yeah and what what
other front is there in this war than
dinner at thanksgiving oh yeah 100
you always have the weirdest [ __ ]
french people from your family coming
out
living
living in the weird s like desert towns
of middle california never heard of
where like people just tweak all day and
you don't know what they do out there
and somehow
i know yeah yeah yeah
well this year is going to be a little
different probably because like half of
them are dead
you know what i'm saying that's
interesting like
you know the the dinner table is going
to be a lot lighter that's interesting a
lot a lot of uncles passed away this
past year might be some leftover turkey
yeah exactly but you know the ones that
did make it the ones that are the true
believers that you know somehow made it
through the covet thing
uh you know get ready
and we're we're gonna give you the tools
we're gonna give you the ammunition yeah
so are able to fight back today we're
gonna be basically
doing
all of the main things you're gonna hear
from your conservative uh brainwashed
family members and the tools you need to
disarm them that's coming up a little
bit later but this is huge guys you're
not going to miss this one in the
meantime
let's enjoy some i asked my community
one thing i'll say is i ask my community
about this like what should like what
are we missing here you know
question-wise
and like
i should have never asked them they're
like oh the the conflict in ethiopia i'm
like no no no like random republican
uncle is gonna be like what's going on
in ethiopia like
yeah i'm
is there is a conflict in ethiopia yes
there's oh no conflict going on
my family won't be discussing that i
think yeah
with peace and love of course
you know
uh but here i'll give you a preview
we've got critical race theory you know
white people are the most discriminated
against it today in society also bonus
karen
is racist against white women you'd be
surprised how often i hear that really
yes
and i've even been hearing tucker doing
that like oh what she's a karen like
they're writing it off like it's some
kind of a
you know white woman hate there are only
two genders
covet is just the flu there's a lot
about covert obviously you know i'm it's
so hard for me not to immediately get
unlocked and like don't don't do it now
trump won the election
you know why are they always canceling
things like mr potato head and jeremiah
i mean in short canceled culture is
ruining society uh
forced diversity affirmative action
young people don't know how to work hard
anymore that's a good one you know
global warming is a hoax
and uh
joe biden bosch to afghanistan so these
are
just a good baseline
to be prepared you know and the the goal
is to make your relative cry
yes you your goal is to make them feel
that the only solution is uh a civil war
and uh secession from the
the united states as we know it
two-nation solution
yeah um
look debates
are in my opinion uh something that is
mostly for entertainment it gives you
the talking points uh for your side
again and it helps you recognize the
other side's talking points i'm not a
firm believer that uh you know this is
the aristocratic uh or the socratic
method or whatever aristocratic um the
socratic method where you are you know
arriving at the truth by debating
someone no it's just like a guy who's
very good rhetorically a rhetorically
gifted person blurting out talking
points and trying to rationalize uh
logical fallacies as quickly as possible
right against another guy who's doing
the same yeah and by the way
rarely in any debate do the people
actually know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about uh yeah
it's usually yeah ben shapiro is not
like this this brilliant scientist that
has a full-blown understanding of uh
climate historian uh climatology exactly
they literally
it's just an appeal to emotions he knows
what plays great on the emotion and
sounds good yeah and when and also like
there are numerous different methods of
making yourself come across like the the
winner to the onlookers ultimately um
you know there's 40 percent of uh one
side that's going to remain there 40 of
the other side that's going to remain
there and you're basically fighting for
the 20 in the middle and they can
potentially sway
depending on how rhetorically uh
superior one side looks you're feeling
pre you're pretty optimistic you think
that we can be changing minds at the
thanksgiving there's always people
well not at the thanksgiving tip i'm
just saying in general if you're like
doing a public debate and it's on
youtube
20 people you could persuade i feel like
it's like five in the margins there's
always people that are just like
onlookers that don't really have like a
super strong well-established position
still the overwhelming majority of
either side is going to stay you know
yeah unless there's like a thorough
uh just uh deconstruction and full-blown
humiliation of the other side if you
just like rip them
yeah i don't think so
yeah i mean ultimately it's
entertainment though and it can be very
entertaining but um you're
like if your goal is to like change the
minds of your relatives especially ones
that watch like
you know hours and hours and hours of
fox news like that's not gonna happen
well anyway you should know just be
ready okay it's happening wars coming
this thanksgiving and we must be ready
to fight i'm seeing the headlines
already ethan kline and hassan biker
want to destroy the nuclear family they
hate families and that's why they're
telling you to let's fight back it's the
new civil war i'm just following what
tim poole told me to do families against
families brothers against brothers you
know yeah
that's right covet nation versus no
nation
i'll tell you which army's gonna last
longer in the trenches the one that's
vaccinated yeah it's a war of attrition
yeah well you know that's uh we're
sterile now though we don't have uh we
can't have babies our immune systems are
dead we got too much okay let's get on
with it okay [ __ ] joe biden is
destroying my own tv we got some memes
at the top of the show you know about it
oh yeah so you guys know about this [ __ ]
joe biden thing
i don't know if we've talked have we
talked about it i don't know if i've
ever explained this weird phenomenon
we briefly brought it up when it was
first popping off and then it turned
into let's go brandon and remember
donald trump jr tried to take credit for
it and be like i made this i made this
believe me he's like no you didn't no
you okay yeah so i guess the back story
with let's go brandon
is that some reporter
people were
chanting [ __ ] joe biden in the stands
and a reporter misheard them and said
they're saying let's go brandon yeah
and so now they they thought that was
hilarious so now they all say let's go
brandon
which is code word for the very naughty
naughty uh yeah [ __ ] joe biden
yeah and i feel terrible for brandon
brown you know it was like a beautiful
moment for him in talladega he wins he's
like elated he's excited and now the
only thing that people remember is like
nobody was saying let's go brandon you
know and that's like the big
conservative thing i feel bad
uh but yeah no this was like a big
conspiracy that like the media is just
hiding the truth about how people are at
talladega you hear that they're saying
let's go brandon oh they're not saying
that they're saying folks about it i've
we could one day look at i've done this
already on my stream but uh there are
many rap songs that have come out oh
there's there's maga rap with the dude
of course dude this entire thing is like
there's a grift economy
oh i've seen that one mega raft rapper
but are they are they going with the
let's go brandon there are like three or
four songs that is just let's go brandon
that's that are titled let's go right
now they were popping off on itunes
charts too am i getting
yeah like number one and number two
something beautiful about like
conservatives hijacking hip-hop to turn
it into some pseudo-white
nationalist movement yeah the jews are
black though or except for except for
forgiato blow josh
who is uh ethnically ambiguous i don't
know what the [ __ ] i mean he's more of a
creature anyway but uh the other two
dudes are the the two uh black rappers
is like the black maga rapper and then
there's another guy who's like trying to
pop off well anyway this guy's so pissed
off he uh
oh no
what's he gonna do
no i'm so owned
dude he [ __ ] owned me don't don't
show it again don't do it oh no
he's owning the libs by smashing his own
tv and this is basically
a good comparison to not getting
vaccinated to own the libs you basically
just put a year and the people around
you like dude
dude he he owned me so hard i don't know
how you're able to sit there it hurts
and joe biden will never recover either
yeah i mean joe biden's ratings are
[ __ ] pretty terrible right now so
but
you know but i mean if people are
smashing their tvs that's good for the
economy they're gonna have to buy new
ones well you know there's uh you know
there's a supply chain problem right now
there's inflation
i mean my man is cooking himself a
little bit you know
i just love that i mean these people are
dumb as it gets destroying their own
property
yeah to show how [ __ ] badass the
nikes remember the colin kaepernick
thing yeah that's so awesome there's a
long history they broke down their
keurigs uh when keurig pulled their
sponsor from sean hannity i think
they've they've done this forever this
is like a classic thing i remember the
the colin kaepernick they were literally
burning their own [ __ ] js yeah all
their nike [ __ ] it's like cool you
already bought it bro well they you
already bought it you you're not
supporting you already paid for it the
other thing is uh they
i mean they do the let's go brandon
thing in a different way forever you
know what i mean like when donald trump
first became president and like owning
globes was super hot hotter than it ever
has been i was feeling so owned all the
time i'm not even a liberal but god damn
i was owned um
and
what they would do is they would go to
starbucks and be like
[Laughter]
i'm gonna get a cup
and i'm going to name myself mega you
know what i mean right like
they do that this is like they're fun
it's just little baby-brained idiots
it's awesome
i love it well this guy milo
yiannopoulos he was really kind of a
prominent right-wing figure for a while
yeah you know he was making the rounds
he was on breitbart everyone went full
libertarian that's what happened well
people thought he was real interesting
ruben report had like a huge thing on
him he was a total piece of [ __ ] i mean
a total psychotic freak show
and it
culminated
when he went on joe rogan's podcast and
uh told some story about how he
uh
like was attracted to children
yeah he talked about like he basically
like i said he went full libertarian
never go full libertarian you can't do
that once you start talking about the
arbitrary uh nature age of consent laws
it's like is that a libertarian talking
plant rothbard famously discussed the
you know child marketplace the
marketplace of children
no way i mean when you when you go full
when you go full and cap when you go
full right libertarian you're inevitably
going to arrive at the conclusion that
like your child is your property and you
could technically sell your child
which is what rothbard argued
which would make it
a famous libertarian thinker so his his
theory was if we take this all the way
to one of many we'll take this all the
way to the logical conclusion there is a
workplace uh
commerce place for children in terms of
like labor sexual objects are we talking
sex slavery
he argued that parents have the right to
put a child out for adoption or sell the
rights to the child in a voluntary
contract and what roth bart suggests
will be
a flourishing free market in children
holy [ __ ] in order to improve child
welfare
free market for the child exchange yeah
he said that
the free market of children would create
a better child welfare because the
parents that really want to have a child
will buy it
have a child
has this guy ever been psychoanalyzed
that's one of the weirdest sickest
things i've ever heard the free market
of children well
milo was definitely interested in the
free market of children if you know what
i mean yeah he went real he went real
french philosopher with it he went real
right libertarian with it and of course
americans were like even american like
funders and a lot of these guys have
like one billionaire that loves them and
i think milo's case was mercer uh they
were like okay that's too much there's a
bridge too far from actually can you
pull that clip up because it was so it
was just an iconic moment and i it's
just
because being on joe rogan show is a big
deal right so
the this is one of the best conservative
fall from graces i've ever seen
yeah um what you see here he's obviously
openly gay he talks about he's not
anymore
that i was getting yeah he's he's
converted he's joined
what's called the church it's so
militant.shop so this is the christians
the christian army which is well i'm
looking at that like very well i'm
looking at that lady she's giving me
real [ __ ] che guevara vibes like
she's the she's the captain
yeah but i love the idea of the cr the
church uh religious militaries are a
good idea yeah totally i mean
yeah she's she looks like a
revolutionary
you know
well
he has renounced homosexuality he's
successfully converted despite still
being the gayest looking and sounding
man
on the planet yeah i don't i don't
believe that he he converted that
success i mean dude i'm sorry but you
cannot rock that haircut on the christ
military.shop and pre and and say that
you're still straight yeah
he he's a he's a horrible monster in
every way i mean he he made a living
like literally going to college campuses
like outing trans people in front of
like the
young uh college republicans that like
invited them there he was a big troll
and
uh he was also like the main guy that
uh utilized the whole like ha ha we're
just joking why are you upset
except it's not jokes like it's actually
very serious like he would try to insert
nazi rhetoric into breitbart articles
you know breitbart which had famously a
black crime
section
titled black crime until until 2017.
that's awesome when ben shapiro used to
work there
uh by the way so you know all these guys
are [ __ ] demons but
well so he was like trying to red pill
people exactly openly which is weird
it's he's obviously has a fair bit of
self-loathing because he aligns himself
with people with actually just hate gay
people like he's continually just
surrounding himself with people that
hate who he is very interesting here he
is selling virgin mary statues so this
is how far it goes so it's eleven and
three-quarter inches tall i think it's
if you're thinking no no i'm saying like
he's fall from grace's hat but it's
awesome to your
shrine or maybe even a bedside table i
know sometimes people like to wake up
and say good morning to their favorites
uh you know people and saints and
whatnot
it's available in bronze and pewter it's
never so satisfying
we're not yet set up for two easy
payments despite our
this is the best [ __ ] thing this is
like the best poetic justice that's ever
happened uh we're not set up for two
payments yet are we
well we're working on that
all things are possible with god am i
right
it's great church militant dot shop
she's
just under 12 inches tall
she's available in this i know what he
was thinking there
just under 12 inches back in the day no
he's converted when i was like
conversion he's he's converted he's a
straight man now this this virgin mary
is the perfect size
two different um they call them accent
finishes
we've got statues in the shop here that
are um fully painted
right and we'll see some of those later
yes but the thing i like about this is
this this wonderful burnished
bronzy aged
uh color that she's got and that
wonderful the face on this is
to make sure that she's got right just
so passionate she's so loving about it
on the other hand as you can see
you know the thing is milo
could have been a a very entertaining
character
if he wasn't also just like a
straight-up psychopath he could have
just been like a regular republican who
was gay and flamboyant and you know
dressed
in an interesting way and kept
triggering the libs because he had the
capacity to do so well he flew too close
to the sun yeah i mean and he just like
literally organized alongside nazis and
stuff and when you do that you're going
to get got eventually okay and you're
going to get de-platformed very
successfully and when that happens
you're done when you're shut off from
your main think you know what's
interesting this is proof that d
platforming works he was banned on every
platform and now this [ __ ] is
selling virgin mary's yeah christian
what the [ __ ] do they sell at church
military so church militant and i'm
looking into it right now it's actually
like an ultra conservative
uh
uh orthodox catholic group that like
they're catholic but they really hate
this pope and they hate any oh yeah
basically a liberal is commissioned this
pope is yeah he's right he's a gay
community what the [ __ ] is a catholic me
too other than people who are raped by
priests
i have no idea
i don't know but the church store is
selling
if you scroll down they're selling what
is known as a chapel veil let me go to
the shop and i have no idea what that is
but i'm into it wait a chapel veil
hey that looks like me bro
like a good that's a good catholic man
oh
well that's baby jesus i'm assuming
because he's got the extra little swag
it is halo you know more about this than
i do i don't know i don't know anything
about christianity what do i know um but
yeah they're selling chapel veils too
which i guess you wear purpleville i
christian militant
um the crusade is back guys
pope is praising journalism
yo these guys got sweat look at that
swag bro yeah they look like dark souls
bosses dude i mean straight up
yeah they do for sure i mean there's
there's literally a dark souls boss
that's like that that's a fat scythe
like that's a good probably a good
weapon the deacon of the deep that's
literally yeah that's like i think
that's probably a dex weapon not a
striker no no no that's plus 10 mage
like uh
magic damage faith so faith build sorry
faith he's a faith builder
it's true um
where's the [ __ ] i want to see the
damn i mean i'm on the church militant
dot shop oh no i'm on the
churchmills.shop website and i'm seeing
like
if you scroll down yeah what is this
but it's a different page than what
you're looking at for some weird reason
come on church militant shot oh yeah
here here just keep going keep going
keep going they got fbi i don't know
what that is fbi dvd's fbi and then
right underneath it you have chapel
veils okay chapel veils what the [ __ ] i
mean it's kind of hot
yeah good for role playing i'm kind of
i'm i'm into it
is that a marriage thing or just like
when you go to church you got to be
modest thing no [ __ ] they've got it
in merlot that's kind of a sexy name i
don't know if you want to invoke yeah
imagine putting lingerie on your head
ladies what's up what's going on you
know you're like oh i'm going to be
super catholic so i'm going to wear
lingerie on my head when i go to church
i'm going to [ __ ] turn on god what is
this
well you know god sees everything that's
exactly that veiling height and [ __ ]
um i'm kind of curious
breeding poor leader
it's all about just [ __ ] talking to
church actually
yeah i feel like these guys are the
church's number one haters
instead of you know
seems not very catholic okay here's an
interesting one the bishop is silent on
the homosexual crisis
fellas is it gay to hold your friend's
face this is a crisis that's what
they're saying we need to stop this here
are are they actually here or they just
oh well they have a video this is
awesome as the successors of the
apostles and you know what's the
gathering that's a high budget
this is a high budget uh set how's this
look at that
how
how are they keeping this alive dude
those virgin mary's i just don't
understand how like
something like this which is because
there's so many competitors like
i get why there's a lot of money man
those like psycho evangelical passes
like i get why they make money because
like they're kind of charismatic they're
telegenic like
they say insane [ __ ] that you want to
hear well like you know those guys who
will make crazy money they're basically
just get rich quick christ memes because
they go pay us and you make more money
yeah yeah you know they do the
prosperity gospel a lot of them so i
kind of get where they're coming they're
like nfts kind of like jesus nfts yeah
yo but milo's in this
doing a a gay man okay
doing a show
about bishop silent on homosexual crisis
this is a gay man speaking on the
homosexual crisis yeah successors of the
apostles in the u.s gather today here in
baltimore one pink elephant is following
them up into the conference room church
militants paul murano exposes the
central problem of the sex abuse
almost 20 years after the boston globe
shined its spotlight on clergy sexual
abuse bishops are still dogging the key
issue of homosexuality in the priesthood
i want to be his compassionate mercy is
the problem not pedophilia yeah what the
[ __ ] i thought the problem was like
pedophilia not homosexuality well in the
eyes of in the eyes of like super
christian people they see it as like one
and the same ironic that milo
yiannopoulos is right there too
[Applause]
didn't he get abused by his priest or
something yes yeah wait hold on hold on
play this clip from joe rogan where he
says he's attracted to children
i can't told you it wasn't a pedophilia
i wasn't sure
i was in my teens 14. i was in my teens
or something like that that's what you
said
i don't know how they rock it and i was
very old england i was in my teens over
here in my country and where you are
right now you've never seen a 15 year
old girl at any point in your life
however old you were you've never seen a
15 year old you thought yeah when i was
15. no
when you [ __ ] dude when you were 25
when you were 30 you would have seen
girls about 15 you thought well i
thought they were little kids no you
didn't i thought she's gonna be hot but
i didn't want to [ __ ] her [ __ ]
you can't tell me what i was born into i
think if you're fortunate born like this
beautiful in this world he's literally
like what are you saying right now do
you know that like people are gonna hear
this and they're gonna see this one of
the great one of the moments where i do
appreciate joe rogan he absolutely
bodied him yeah he's just like no
because i'm not a freak
yeah he goes on to say that you know he
was a teenager his priest had sex with
them and he liked it you know he
cherished it pretty interesting
obviously he was the victim in that
situation yeah criticize him for that
[ __ ] him up but now he's on a [ __ ]
the church military
talking about homosexuality is the
problem and not pedophilia incredibly
the 2002 dallas charter in the 2004 john
jay report commissioned by the bishops
focused only on the abuse of minors yes
with the help of the luciferian media
that's the [ __ ] problem
is i can't believe they've all they
would only focus on pedophilia oh what
they would only focus on the smaller
issue of the two yeah miners it's not a
big deal that's like a bonus prize that
you get when you're a priest i don't
understand sex is with kids is one thing
but homosexuality consenting adults
having sex with one another
oh that that's where i draw the line
holy [ __ ] absolutely not madness
pedophilia
thousands of priests were abusing
children priests abusing children more
than 10 000 children were reportedly
sexually abused by catholic priests the
report found almost 80 percent of minors
victimized between 1950 and 2002 were
post-pubescence and of those 85 percent
were male in the 1980s most of that
guy's a [ __ ] rapist
[Laughter]
allegedly i don't know bro i get buried
in minecraft he does he does have those
[ __ ]
cult leader glasses no no no no no no
he's got them waco fours dude look at
those uh that's good eyewear i have some
of those too you like us i love those i
mean i wear them when i want to look
like a [ __ ] pastor like when is that
bro
all the time i love larping dude i i'm
i'm a conservative brother
i'm a real i'm a real red blooded
american
you know you might as well dress up as
jimmy savelle while you're at it
yeah
damn
yeah
um
of all the places and all the things in
the world that we criticize he does
looks us
the one thing me as a parent i would
never [ __ ] leave my kid with the
catholic church under any circumstance
bro i'm telling you
do not put your kids in the church for
any reason you can go to church with
them
go sunday don't leave them there by
themselves never never no shock please
god never
never
holy [ __ ]
i mean look that's that's the priest
dude that's what i'm saying this man is
gonna be holding your child you hand you
you leave your you leave your young boy
at the church what do you what do you do
this guy shows up
this guy's a phd apparently of uh he's
looking like a boyle brother from always
sunny you know what i mean
he's just
not good [ __ ] vibes okay i'm sorry no
disrespect maybe he's like a really nice
dude but he's just
he's looking he's looking to type in a
certain type of way people are gonna get
so mad at us let's throw to a break we
got uh thank our sponsors and we come
right back with more
leftovers
listen up you hairy mother heifers have
you looked in the mirror recently like
really look the beard you grow out over
the last year that covet beer come on
this time let's clean it up a little bit
hassan
they broke your name they wrote your
name and i'm i'm cleaning i'm yeah you
look cleaned up thank you yeah
uh you know what for a minute it's it's
hot outside that's a good thing let's
tame that bad boy it's not hot outside
it's literally winter i mean it's winter
but it is it was like 90 degrees over
the weekend yeah in l.a but everywhere
else in the world harry's changing the
ad copy adjusting it to climate change
well yeah right
exactly 90 minutes it's 90 degrees
outside in the middle of november get a
shave in by with harry's here's the deal
with harry's okay if you don't know
harry's it's time you do harry's was
created to be different from other
shaving companies harry's crafts high
quality long lasting blades and durable
weighted handles that make a close
comfortable shave quick and dare we even
say enjoyable can you dare to say it i
wouldn't yeah they they dare though they
dare you to they're bold yeah
and because harry's insists that you
shouldn't have to choose between a great
shave and a fair price they just give
you both wow i i because i do hate uh
choosing between a great shave and a
pair of hair
i'm always like saved how do i keep
praise
harry's
refill blades start as low as two bucks
easy decision and even easier new
harry's customers get their start here
set which includes a five blade razor
weighted handles foaming gel aloe and a
travel cover it's 13 dollars of value
just for three dollars that's value yeah
and like we've talked about before
you can fight off uh
home invaders with your with your heavy
handle harry's yeah blade yeah it
doubles as a melee weapon yeah that's
right uh plus harry offers a whole range
of amazing face and body care products
for men i'll deliver right to your door
i love harry's i use it on myself i use
it on the back of my neck and use it on
my neckline sometimes on my face when
i'm feeling weird and wild and i want to
look like a pudgy ass mr potato head
don't look good without facial hair
but when i do i use harry's
it's a great razor like no other doesn't
leave the burn it's weighty
and when i look see myself without hair
i want to clunk myself out anyway so
yeah you use the use the heavy handle i
melee weapon myself
there's never been a better time to try
harry's go to harrys.com leftovers to
get their starter set for just three
bucks it's a 100 satisfaction guaranteed
so you got nothing left to lose go to
harrys.com leftovers right now to get
their special offer that's
h-a-r-r-y-s dot com slash leftovers
thank you
listen we all shop online
we've all seen that code taunting us at
checkout that's where honey comes in
it's the free shopping tool that scours
the internet for promo codes and applies
the best one to fights to your card i
like the analogy my dad was a serial
coupon cutter to my great embarrassment
as a child and like this is going gonna
be sparing kids like me of having those
super cheap dads
i don't i love i love a deal i love a
good deal no no my dad would show up to
the grocery store like up with a deck of
pokemon cards and he'd be like doing
like i got like four of a kind bro he'd
be like i respect that it's embarrassing
as a kid it's important oh no way no way
that's awesome well you know what it
takes it out i don't got to be
embarrassed by my dad
you don't know what it's like you don't
know what it's like i don't know what
it's like for sure but like i i would do
that
do you no well then you wouldn't no well
i mean i don't even know where you could
get a coupon
other than the honey well my dad did
well you don't got to worry about
coupons because honey does everything
automatically right honey supports over
30 000 stores online ranging from tech
gaming products fashion brands and even
food delivery imagine you're shopping at
one of your favorite sites when you go
to check out the honey button drops down
all you have to do is click apply coupon
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons you can find for that site and
bob is your uncle if honey finds a
coupon code it'll price it'll drop the
price magically i do love that even if
it's like a dollar off i'm like yes i
want that thing here especially because
like
when i see the co when i see the code uh
up there and i don't have a code
i'm like i feel like i'm missing out
yeah what do they know that i don't know
well what's going on here
you know i on a deal i've spent some
time in my day at the checkout being
like okay new egg or whatever am you
know coupon code and you're like try try
nothing works
the newegg does that all for you and you
don't got to worry about it it saves me
money all the time here this is this one
from ila
yeah this was like three days ago she
sent this to me yep five bucks
there you go five bucks
there you [ __ ] have it the proof is
in the pudding um and i'll tell you what
dude honey has founded 17 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings
jeff bezos be like what have you done
for me lately yeah
not saving me i just found two billion
dollars under my cushion not impressed
if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings it's literally free it stalls in
a few seconds and by getting you're
gonna be doing yourself a solid and
supporting this podcast i'd never
recommend something i don't use get
honey for free at jointhoney.com
leftovers that's jointhoney.com
leftovers thank you thank you
all right we're coming up on thanks to
stamps.com hassan i know you're a sim
for uh the post office i do love me the
post office for sure you're gonna love
stamps.com oh yeah because it brings you
the power of the post office right to
your freaking home no way
yes you're skipping lines you're dodging
lines i do hate lines and you're saving
money like the lines same said calm baby
let you compare rates print labels and
access exclusive discounts on ups and
usps services all year long it just
makes sense especially if your business
sends more mail and packages during the
holiday
you know um
dan's girlfriend uses stamps.com she
loves it don't you
she does she was uh printing out tons of
postage yesterday because the holiday
shopping season has started and shout
out getting lots of orders rolling in
and she was packing them up and boom
boom boom with their little stamps.com
printer printing them out
gets picked up you're taking the post
office
when dan talks i trust him more because
he's like in the mainframe
yeah no no he's in the matrix he has
access to all data points exactly yeah
so if you're selling
online or you're running an office or a
side hustle stamps.com to save you so
much time money and stress during the
holidays access at all post office and
ups shipping services is all you need
well no hold on let me go back access
all the post office and ups shipping
services you need without taking the
trip and get discounts you couldn't find
anywhere else like 40 off ups
and 76 percent off ups
going to the post office instead of
using stamps.com it's kind of like
taking the stairs instead of the
elevator
love that
love the elevators hate the stairs yeah
that's universal yeah
just going up the escalator that's not
working in which case let me use it you
know i'll still use why are you stopping
me from using the escalator that's not
working right stairs now right that's
true
just going up a couple floors
sure take the stairs walking up there we
don't need the extended analogy
stamps.com
if we get it
we don't need more stairs analogies well
you know save time and money exactly
that's what it's all about you're going
to save so much time and money something
about stairs uh and escalators you'll
wonder why
you're saving time and money by skipping
that analogy just like you save time and
money this holiday season with
stamps.com exactly
exactly sign up with the promo code
leftover for a special offer that
includes a four-week trial free postage
and a digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the page and enter leftover
thank you so much
all right let's keep it moving because
we got to get to our main segment today
so let me just hit these headlines let's
do it having too much fun here today uh
guys cueing on shaymin goes to jail for
3.5 years
smell you later
actually this is breaking news i don't
know if you saw his lawyer made a
statement
epic yeah
[Music]
by the way bad sign when you're judge
when your lawyer is like oh you want my
opinion yeah
at the press conference yeah okay here
you go you know my opinion is
meaningless i will say that i would
probably be far more effective over a
beer with president former president
trump
even if he didn't have a beer because i
understand he doesn't drink beer but i'd
have a beer
and i tell him you know what you got a
few [ __ ] things to do
including clearing this [ __ ] mess up
and taking care of a lot of the
jackasses that you [ __ ] up because of
january 6th
now in the meantime i might talk to him
about some other things so i'd agree
with him more
but my opinion doesn't mean [ __ ]
you gotta love this character my lawyer
dog i'm going to jail for three and a
half years
senator that's awesome bro look at my
lawyer dog i got a few [ __ ] words for
that [ __ ] guy yeah no but even then
he's like still sucking off to trump
he's like oh dude we'd agree on a lot of
things though you know it's like yeah we
get it bro you're a conservative
trial lawyer like that's
clear love it
classy all the way george peterson uh
where would we be without men jordan
peterson
this i thought was a photoshop no um
i saw this and i said this isn't real
jordan peterson quote tweeted himself
which is awesome and he said to himself
come say that to my face and we'll see
who needs a benzo bucko you bendy around
words like racist to smear people
without consequence for you
or so you presume as you naively presume
i defy you to find one phrase i ever
uttered that is racist you sanctimonious
slandering arrogant careless little
prick
yeah all the it was just but what's
interesting is it's just some random
twitter account yeah you just said jb
getting triggered and going full race
prick sounds like somebody needs a benzo
oh that's pretty good though yeah that's
pretty good
but welcome to twitter jordan i mean i
want to tell you you can't lose your
mind on over every stupid twitter
comment yeah dude but then he quote
tweets himself you know i think he was
like trying to quote tweet him again but
he's like too much of a boomer to
[ __ ] do that yeah he's just like come
and say that to my face so come say that
to my face you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's just
like weird that he also like admits that
he was you know addicted to the benzos
there too like and you know it's just
like an odd thing what would him do well
it was just a great piece of media where
would we be without benzos men they're
doing impossible things we're doing
impossible things we're getting in
fights on twitter
they're taking the five benzo pills at a
time sometimes sometimes ten women can't
take that much bentos their body can't
handle it yeah they're going to they're
going to to to russia for experimental
treatment and almost dying
because they go cold turkey there and
then their daughters are almost killing
them in serbia because she wanted to go
to a nightclub that's the dragon of
chaos
where would we be
yeah these these
postmodernist neo-marxists don't want
you to know about the dragon of chaos
daughters
toxic masculinity uh that's that i'm
moving along i'm going on to
paul gossard
oh yeah the guy whose whole family made
a campaign ad saying don't vote for him
yeah anime anime titty paul gosar uh is
being censured and is being removed from
his committee positions because the
american government is expressly
anti-anime and i think that's uh
understandable that's a reasonable i'm
not anti-anime i'm just anti-anime i'm
anti-weebs and i myself am an anime fan
but weebs are [ __ ] they're annoying
okay let's get on to this basically
we've got the tim cass legion of doom
this was huge tim apparently does a
podcast out of his trailer
and somehow joe rogan
uh and alex jones all popped in at the
same
time they got the vibes so perfect in
that [ __ ] trailer like it just looks
so
like the filter that they applied or the
lighting makes it look so much smellier
than it actually then it i mean it's
perfectly smelly like the way it is
the way it's supposed to be
yeah so we made a super it was three
hours long but we made a super cut of
our favorite moments here so let's take
it one bit at a time
that's right so joe rogan in the house
alex jones ladies and gentlemen right
about basically everybody by the way
sorry i'm already pausing but you can
really appreciate what a goblin joe is
in that
that setting you know yeah
yeah he's uh it's kind of funny because
it's like everyone is so
excited to be around him like this is
their guy this is
like i i think he he's like a cow you
know what i mean a beautiful cow
running through the field ripe and ready
to be suckled on the teats of and all
these little baby cells or little baby
cows are like running up to him like joe
give me
give me a little bit give me a little
bit of your titty i need to utter joe
yeah and that's that's basically the
vibes of the entire [ __ ] two hour
three hour or whatever yeah he's gonna
become their idol for sure
thing finally it's all coming down the
truth is coming out so thomas jefferson
was in the illuminati bunch of demons
joe rogan is the 46th president of the
united states
oh my god
people are just giving us money
yeah so that that was awesome
yeah i i saw the super chats it's like
five hundred dollars five hundred
dollars five hundred dollars
and you know nothing perfectly shows the
grift someone said some people made 10k
i think like there's like data you can
track you make 10k from the two hour
podcast from the donations alone that's
pretty incredible and that that's the
grift right that that's it right there
yeah
you tell people what they want to hear
you make them feel smart you make them
feel privileged
they give you money it's awesome yeah
and uh
oh god
alex jones is wanting a piece of that
after his ass just got served
uh he's gonna alex jones about to be
bankrupt
uh yeah
yeah he's got
i don't know what kind of insurance you
have to protect yourself from situations
like that where you lie about a [ __ ]
mass shooting uh happening i don't think
alex jones is insurable first of all
yeah
yeah and by the way i just
do you find it a little [ __ ] that joe
rogan who tries to maintain himself as
kind of like a you know open-minded
middle road guy
is happy to associate with someone like
alex jones who
now has been found guilty at least by
default anyway uh enough though of
harassing
the parents
of children who were murdered in sandy
hook
uh
alex jones is a [ __ ] vile psychotic
conspiracy theorists he's entertaining
and lovable i mean look at his face he's
a [ __ ] he looks like psychotic uh you
know santa claus i i'm fascinated with
alex jones we've talked about this
before when i when i came on your
podcast ones like i
i wish that we were at a point in our uh
society where everyone is educated
enough to like appreciate alex jones in
the same way that i read
where you just see him as like an
entertaining figure
in the same way that like for example
link later saw him originally and like
literally put him in like a bunch of
movies because alex jones was in a bunch
of movies scanner darkly like he played
himself or a conspiracy theorist and
like wasn't that link later
yeah it is yeah richard linklater put
him in a lot of movies famously like
um
playing like the role of a conspiracy
theorist you know firebrand whatever and
i love like i love how entertaining he
can be but also i understand how
damaging it is when like so many people
are brain diseased and think he's being
honest way too dangerous he's he's just
he's i don't think you can honestly like
i don't joe co-signs him i mean he
really does and no he was not okay he
would be the greatest entertainer like
one of the greatest entertainers if
uh he was not such a [ __ ] horrible
monster and his followers did not
actually believe everything he was
saying yeah
well joe rogan costumes that he the new
meme now is like he's been right about
everything he keeps saying [ __ ] like
that yeah which
comedian by the way it's one of my
favorite memes it's like it's so you are
hear me
you're such a [ __ ] boomer like jesus
christ he went from like
being a comic that i appreciated and
like you know people have always said
like his comedy is mid but i mean i like
some of his specials to like hey look at
this facebook meme i found that my you
know that my children sent me take a
look here i'll send it to you hahaha
it's like ugh come on
right now make that larger make that
meme larger look at that [ __ ] hold on
your tv is buying a new check
elite cabal of sex traffickers check are
we uh not jack they're turning the frogs
gay
it's like
it's from africa right yeah yeah so
bohemian grove checks what is bohemian
we know bohemian groves yeah yeah so
here's the thing okay this is something
that like alex jones gets a lot of
credit for for some [ __ ] weird reason
i'm a huge conspiracy uh lover i love
conspiracy theories
um your tv spying on you is correct
elite cabal of sex traffickers you could
absolutely say existing form of like you
know uh
jeffrey epstein and and whatnot
um certainly right
uh whether it's like you know cia
compromise there is there is legitimacy
to a certain degree not in the way that
like alex jones is portraying it they're
turning the frogs gay is not like
they're not turning the frogs gay but
like pesticide is actually changing
their uh hormones and
and um you know turning frogs into uh i
think they're trending as far as trans
kind of hermaphrodites uh hermaphrodites
bohemian grove is a [ __ ] club that is
well documented i know people that have
literally worked there in the past as
well it's uh it's just a place for
like conservative rich men to get away
from their wives and like you know
express their desires to be theater kids
yes alongside celebrities richard nixon
famously said like
the f word when talking about it he's
like a bunch of
you know it's everywhere it's turning
into the bohemian grove a bunch of
f-wordy uh you know
rich people dancing around in the woods
frolicking into the woods and that is
what they do so it's not as like severe
because the elites when they get
together they're not getting together at
the [ __ ] bohemian grove to like
figure out what they're doing they're
getting together in sun valley idaho
okay it's sun valley idaho they do this
once a year that's where jeff bezos
decided to purchase washington post it's
it's in front of your eyes they get
together at the davos summits they get
together the aspen ideas festival they
don't have to go to the [ __ ] they
don't need in the cold ritual to [ __ ]
yeah yeah the whole thing is is silly
silver iodide is [ __ ] turns you blue
rich people using baby blood true
literally true blood boys peter thiel
has blood boys uh so there is not baby
blood but you know
wait what the [ __ ] are you talking about
so uh blood boys is a very real thing
blood boys yes
okay so peter thiel
uh and other people conservative yeah oh
yeah he's a huge libertarian and do they
did are they thinking of him when they
give the chapman up here no they're just
like using this to okay what does he do
tell me about the blood boys so blood
boys is when you get um like a young a
young lad
how young women give you like 17 18
whatever like younger
uh person to uh do a blood transfusion
with okay and they believe that it has
like potential healing properties and
also like you know
peter thiel does that yeah
for sure yeah i mean it's just a blood
silicon valley made fun of it but it is
literally real
so they do just an unnecessary blood
transfusion
yeah
tech crunch no peter thiel is not
harvesting himself with the blood of the
young
like it's not they're not bathing in
virgin blood or anything like that but
they do actually do blood transfusions
in a similar way that like uh
what's the the guy with the one ball uh
michael
the the biker
oh uh lance lance lance yeah like lace
armstrong not mine lance armstrong did
that like people that want to cheat in
the olympics do the same the same exact
thing
really yeah
so they get that young blood in there by
the way there's literally a [ __ ]
company by the way
theo has been interested in cheating
death for several years told businesses
either back in 2012 death is a problem
that can be solved the company is called
ambrosia which got uh which takes
donated teen blood and pumps it into
anyone age 35 or older for eight
thousand dollars a pop
well
that is interesting and a little creepy
but i don't know if that would say
that's rich people using baby blood no
no that's what i'm saying they take
something this is something that
conspiracy theories do because you guys
do regularly they take something that's
like real that's insane
okay but instead of just being like
that's real and it's insane
they turn it into something that is
surreal and psychotic and well their
theory was that they they used the blood
of babies there's some magic in it what
was it called migrocro to clone or some
[ __ ] like that adrenal chrome yeah yeah
so but anyway here silver iodide not
really sure
i'm not really sure people using baby
blood i'm not that's true no it's
happening down in mexico right now is
you are here human monkey chimeras which
he predicted a long time ago where is
that where is that where's the wait
you're saying the elves aren't real
that's no no that's next well the elves
are real of course they're real they're
coming and then i talked to a lot of
people that were uh
the second amendment advocates
they were saying before the election
they were going back into their
instagrams and their facebooks and
finding posts from eight nine years
briefly look at that for those people
imagine it's one thing for a
an orthodoxy to take over and make you
comply but to punish you before it took
over is thought crime
before i mean this is mind control this
is this is this is like in science
fiction this was never drinking i don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
people they're talking about people
getting banned they're talking about
people getting banned from facebook
because like at the end at the end of
the day like
there's a bunch of [ __ ] boomers
like saying the government's censoring
us or private corporations
of them with guns and then they i don't
even believe that that's a real story
for the record
he's a [ __ ] anecdote at best
and not only a thought crime they're
going back in time and punishing us for
for old photos to come to our house and
90 of the time like when you it's so
hard to get banned from [ __ ] facebook
and twitter and [ __ ] like i have literal
psycho stalkers and [ __ ] that i like
report regularly and
they still pop up with like stock
accounts and stuff so it's just like
it's total [ __ ] that you know it's
these guys are getting banned so easily
for being conservative it's like no they
probably were like literally being like
i'm gonna murder you and that's why they
got [ __ ] banned not because they have
photos of guns yeah teamed up where
you're punished for behavior before the
new orthodoxy comes in so you don't just
submit in the current state you're going
to pay for not
adopting it
you really get that this isn't science
fiction this is what they did in the
soviet union where if you were on the
wrong side before it took over you were
executed with your family but this has
historical presence
i love that i i yeah no the the soviet
union they would uh throw you in the
gulag yeah and that's the same as like
you getting banned off [ __ ] fights
mark zuckerberg is coming to uh to uh
disappear you in the middle of the night
meanwhile they're having this
conversation about facebook and that's
the most insane part of this because it
is literally by far the most heavily
right-wing slang [ __ ] website out of
all the major social medias that like if
you look at the top 10 posts top 10 uh
best performing posts on facebook every
week and kevin rose of the new york
times like closely tracks up here um
breitbart like yeah it's literally
always like far right news like what do
you want what more do you want well
that's why they get facebook they they
turn they're just turning into a right
wing conspiracy stomping ground because
they're pushing and pushing them pushing
them they got all these boomers using it
it's turned into their bread and butter
and america at least is just a
white angry christian conspiracy
theorist and uh that's that's their
dollar that's their market
point would you start red pilling your
kids or do you that's [ __ ] awesome
dude i love the idea of red pilling your
kids
oh you know what after joe leaves you
i'm i'm gonna block pill i did not watch
the rest of this but like i watched the
first hour when joe was there
and that dude in the middle is like a
quote-unquote journalist he's like one
of those like [ __ ] andy no types
right and he was used as a witness on
the trial in the kenosha trial
uh that's why he's there
and he was just blurting the entire time
in the first hour he's just blurting
right-wing talking points like sean
hannity and you can see joe rogan is so
annoyed he's like why the [ __ ] is this
loser that's sitting behind me even
having a say in this conversation
i mean he's in a trailer with [ __ ]
tim paul his credentials aren't that
much more interesting
yeah i mean i'm just i'm saying that he
was very obvious that he [ __ ] hated
this dude i've left my children alone
and i've got four children so one's like
19 117 one's 13 one's four
but i always think please stop having
kids alex jones that's what he's just
four or five because i mean damn
the other one and i'm
it's not an accident that alex jones is
sitting next to conservative trans
commentator blair white for the record
we do know he's the chaser okay
oh that's true he left the browser open
mm-hmm alex is into the transport
and apparently like uh
apparently i don't know if blair talks
about it in this one but apparently he
like
was alex jones that reached out to her
when she had like ten thousand
positioned her ten thousand when she had
ten thousand followers like like when
she was first starting off like you
positioned her for say i think it was
alex jones let's go i don't want to
slander alex jones but we know for a
fact that he's a chaser because we saw
him slander alice we saw his uh you know
we saw his we got the documents we got a
here's the ariel
yep here's a aerial view of alex jones
phone where you can see he's looking at
uh you know transport right there
naughty t babe marissa
that's the dude that was the best flip
up of all time he's like it's like dude
if it's on your phone too like how
desperate are you like yeah he left i
used my fap top you know he he's like
he's like i really need to get this one
out well he left the browser open that
means that he just he nutted was in like
post nut you know obviously your browser
left the browser open
that's so good yeah that's the best
thing ever yeah
i mean good for you alex get it like
that's why i feel guilty so like she
knows how to run like i don't know how
to turn the tv on so i don't watch a lot
of it it's like all these she says i'm
gonna put music on i want my brother
that she's like and all of a sudden
sanjay gupta and i'm like shrilling a
steak i'm like
i'm like really eating it i'm like huh
and then like goop does do so i go turn
it off
i'm telling you my daughter is is like
like a demon conjuring sanjay gupta so
this is his daughter
we got a [ __ ] red pill here quick we
gotta exercise you don't got kids don't
look at me are you just like jesus
the best part was tim's here
you guys remember he famously was like
i'm single and it's not my fault it's
the whole world's fault so here is a
little sad uh important kids don't look
at me are you just like nobody was
looking at you bro
nobody was looking it's because he goes
on dates and he's still wearing the
beanie dude just take the beanie off and
one of these [ __ ] dates dog i swear
to god like it's gotta be worse we're
gonna get some [ __ ] homie we're under
there has got to be worse than 34 and i
have no family because my dad had two
kids by the time he was 27 yeah and i'm
like man
you know what you know the problem is
though
it's definitely not me
i think it's
everybody else yeah
i love that video because it's like it's
literally the meme like he
he doesn't even realize like it's not me
it's everyone else
don't look at me
[Laughter]
poor guy or tim he's not like terrible
looking well just take we got to see
what's going on under the beanie
yeah i mean there is a photo from when
he was like posting on 4chan we put put
a shoe on his head and stuff like the
thing is it's definitely a personality
thing i'm sorry to say no he's fine
looking yeah he's looking he's like a
decent looking dude he's rich i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on maybe his
rv smells bad but you know other than
that
it's like are you just like
you want to come back to my rv yeah joe
broken and alex jones were here you can
still smell them on the scene
oh that's not that bad here's a photo of
him under the beanie it's really not
that bad he's got typical male pattern i
mean it's a definitely deep pattern yeah
i mean you can't speak on this okay i
can i take propecia
you can't speak on the hairline king
this is like me dunking on like whatever
you got every [ __ ] thing you got
everything look at this look at this i
don't give a [ __ ] about your hair bro
you're like tall and jacked i mean i'm
fine right now thanks thanks to [ __ ]
i hope you go balls how about that
i [ __ ] because you have everything
else you deserve to go bald it's all
guys like me have is the pr is the hope
of prayer the guy's like you follow it
peter is mad that's why i don't have it
that's why i don't have it out and about
right now
but how dare you yeah you know what [ __ ]
you it's like that's what you get for
being 6'4 yeah
male pattern baldness
um but it's he actually looks totally
fine actually i think he looks better
without the beanie because he wears it
so deep too you know why doesn't he just
go full bald i don't understand just
like gave it off embrace it man you know
and people praise dan he he wears the
dome with pride and people love it
yeah you know yeah white pride i'm just
kidding wow there's a lot of tim pool
memes just popped up
but uh let's not go there
i think we're getting short
we got to be
we gotta keep cruising we're burning
time here yeah we're getting only got
two hours wow
okay let's just watch it like this
that's my discord oh that's no that's
you that's my that's my discord pfp it's
not real i just like they [ __ ] with
your teeth or something yeah they put
like the uh the smile filter on it i
think okay yeah something not done not
looking right there yeah it looks like
they're watching my discord pfp in the
in the second screen
they're like you know i i don't i want
to say i respect my children i do
but it's weird it's like i can't like
tell a four-year-old how things work
they see it so i'm just like we're
turning sanjay off now and she's
throwing a fit and she doesn't know why
your four-year-old is not watching sanja
and throwing a fit bro
that never happened why is she not like
i don't know watching baby shark or some
[ __ ] no don't turn off sanjay gupta is
my favorite show
telling my daughters alex
next time i gotta turn this off this is
this is scary
nobody's literally being like alex your
four-year-old doesn't watch sanjay gupta
yeah that's really weird
it's a lie
that's what you tell her yeah it's very
scary well children are a lot more
conscious a lot more aware they actually
have a lot more dmt going through their
brain up until a certain age so they're
in touch with my favorite guy i love
that he goes tell your child this is
very scary we want them to be scared of
things lots of things this is a good
healthy child psyche
be scared this is you'd be scary
he's a brown man on the television okay
this is a hulk yeah yeah we're in a cult
yeah
this information is not based on reality
this is a left-wing cult and they're
they're pumping stuff out and then
they're confirming this belief they're
they're all getting together and they're
ignoring contrary evidence yes they're
ignoring any narrative that challenges
their belief about what happened and
they're not looking at it realistically
they're only looking at it like you
would look at it if you're in a [ __ ]
cult sounds like a legendary sounds like
joe rogan talking about ivory mix yeah
exactly
yeah i'm assuming they're talking about
kovid which is so [ __ ] ironic because
this man has gotten pretty much
everything wrong he ignores all this do
i have a health czar bro he better watch
it
you know yeah aaron rodgers doctor bro
he turned into this figurehead on the
right yeah aaron rodgers people are
calling him for health advice sorry can
you suck your own [ __ ] yeah that's right
joe rogan can allegedly so that was a
big story i'm gonna get my i'm gonna get
my health information from that guy yeah
that's what i'm going to do his dick at
the at the rate he takes i ever met him
he basically his his [ __ ] is 50
ivermectim at this point so he's on a
permanent drip just deworming deworming
that's awesome
and yep you know beard left well cult is
a religion that's just like it's just
older now
about it though cult doesn't let you ask
questions so keep going but a cult is
made by a guy and that guy knows it's a
cult in a religion that guy's dead
that's the difference like religions are
just cultures he's like doing reddit
atheism memes and i like i don't even
disagree with him all that much he's
just saying that like
and economic and and even uh but moral
i'm talking about his old bit about how
like the difference between scientology
and and like catholic what is he talking
about he's talking about [ __ ]
he's talking about covid treatments
yeah he
well he's talking about uh i i don't
remember if this was about kenosha or is
he's talking about mainstream media
though he's talking about liberal bias
in mainstream media and how cult-like it
is right and um obviously it doesn't
stick there but if he's making a
comparison between religion and uh like
other cults
that are newer than that i understand
what he's saying and that's what he's
like he's using that to expand upon his
criticism of mainstream media
sure it's like they actually benefit
society like some some cults they're
based on rituals or things that people
learn and they realize this is a better
way to live their life and but some of
them are just based on the present
moment of gathering the most amount of
whether it is uh influence or finances
or
what what power whatever the [ __ ] it is
that's what this is you know what i
totally agree the reason the reason the
reason i called is joe rogan by the way
i totally agree with you joe you're so
smart and billion you're also six foot
four and you're super rich by the way
and powerful
it's kind of sad seeing alex jones like
suck joe's boots so hard though like
they all are doing it but it's like alex
you're a [ __ ] full-grown like adult
well alex is basically lost without joe
i mean joe is the only reason he has any
relevance left today nobody we were
watching that show if it wasn't for joe
having him on yeah and then revitalizing
him you know and now that he just got
these these uh
verdicts against him this [ __ ]
is gonna be
uh [ __ ] deep
on joe
this is his only chance
well okay let's get on with it we're
coming to the end we got to do these
serving w's at dinner
um this is the big this is the big show
here
i see what happened there
must've been a mistake because i have
such a large dome
all right
here's the premise i'm gonna be playing
the uh
the uh you know
the dumbass which is not far from the
truth no okay i'll be cosplaying as
basically myself
and you're gonna wanna be hassan okay so
we're gonna we're gonna role play this
i'm the haas and i'll be headed
thanksgiving all right you guys ready i
wish i had like overalls and a piece of
hay in my mouth i was gonna bring my
trump hat today i forgot well hold on
can i at least get some like uh maggot
[ __ ] to put on yeah you got all the mega
[ __ ] there
he's just he's just grabbing
oh my god yeah i've got the bomb oh oh
no
i got the box of maggots falling apart
brother let's see i got to pick right
for this segment we've got the
i mean this is a favorite white straight
conservative how it's going to offend
you today
we've got the uh this is unrelated
[Music]
we've got the
yellow line tow truck lives matter
[Music]
yeah that one's not good
we've got the um
[Music]
let's see here
when i die don't let me vote democrat
that's good that's good i love that
with the punisher let's do that one okay
with the punisher decal
teddyfresh.com
straight ripping it how about just
shirtless
that's actually pretty funny as long as
as long as you wear like one of those
conservative hats and shirtless like
yeah
whatever
[ __ ] ah it's my house damn it this is
my house
this is my dinner table damn it and i
won't wear no shirt if i want to uncle
hank this is not your house
it's not
yeah
now that i'm no longer a whiskey now
that i'm no longer uns now that i'm no
longer shackled by deborah who left me
[Music]
i can
i can drop trout if i want to
it's my freedom it's my right you cannot
tell me to wear a shirt that's against
my god-given right i mean it's the same
energy as the mask no mess 100 you know
right so then hat wise
we've got oh there you go
that's such a high quality photo i love
that it's like
like mike did a photo shoot like that he
might even be eating thanksgiving dinner
it looks like resolution is really hot
you can see all the individual uh body
hair he is one of those guys who would
order like thanksgiving dinner at a
diner you know yeah
it's sad but you know another brave
victim of divorce court
all right i'm in character when i die
don't let me vote democrat ooh
and the nra hat okay i'm in character
okay let's let's hear what you got for
me all right so i'm gonna be at the
dinner table
i tell you what
that critical race theory
is ruining
our schools
they're teaching our kids
that they's born racist
okay so one of the immediate things that
you got to ask is
for them to define what critical race
theory is i don't know critical race
theory
it means that
we're racist
this ain't no racist country we got rid
of slavery
black people can vote
i ain't no racists around here
okay so conservatives consider
everything to be critical race theory
everything that like revolves around
race to be critical race theory so you
gotta figure out what brand of like
critical race theory your relative is
talking about if they're talking about
like
uh you know anything that mentions uh
black people as like human beings even
in the like pre-abolition world in the
pre-reconstructed era and that's
critical race theory you're talking to
someone who's like you know lost in the
sauce in which case you should just like
thoroughly embarrass them by
uh you know mentioning that slavery is
immoral and wrong and uh slavery's been
gone for a hundred years what you talk
about slavery except ain't no slaves
around here boy exactly except the
intergenerational consequences of you
know shadow slavery ripping people away
from their families raping them and
selling them obviously that still
remains that was 200 years ago you tell
me them blacks ain't got time to get
their [ __ ] together [ __ ] my family moved
here
but after slavery and we we're doing
great here exactly no problem because
your family had rights and liberties
that were not afforded the black people
so much so that even after abolition uh
even after the abolition of slavery
racist people the democrats okay the
demon rat uh you know the demons
were trying to keep that alive they keep
that separation alive through enforcing
uh jim crow laws and segregating black
people and not offering them the same
opportunities
so much so that
every single uh uh african descendant of
slave slaves here in the united states
right now
is still one and a half generations
removed from abject poverty from
complete poverty that was systematically
enforced upon them that they were you
know forced into i just don't think that
our kids need to go to school and learn
that they're born
racist that don't make no kind of sense
what is born raises you just learn
racism in uh
through stereotypical imagery and and
through your sound
system you sound like call me skim
that's right
i don't believe none of that
so
yeah so one thing that you can do is
basically talk about like listen this is
not happening once you identify what
kind of critical race theory they're
operating on what they're talking about
one thing that you can talk about is
obviously how whitewashed the uh
historical perspective historical
narrative is and that um if anything you
know a
true understanding of history so that
everyone can understand and and you know
be better equipped
is by teaching people honestly teaching
kids honestly about america's history
with racism there's nothing wrong with
like learning about this process and one
thing that i do hear regularly when i
was in school i heard that they're
separating my white kids and saying
you're black now and you got to pretend
like you're discriminated against now
what kind of crazy [ __ ] is that
i heard that there's kids in school they
get separated and they say you're the
slaves and then the other kids say
you're you're the oppressor my kid ain't
no oppressor and he ain't no black
either
so
so the thing is like well this is a
common thing that i hear a lot where
people say
they're teaching our kids that they're
villains in this story and no you're not
you
you should not feel white guilt for what
your ancestors did however you should be
guilty and feel guilty if you're still
defending it now okay so that's the big
problem here and the big disconnect i
think is that like learning about uh
america's history doesn't automatically
make you a villain continuously
defending it in 2021 i ain't defending
it it's just that
ain't no systemic racism here ain't no
laws against black people y'all you all
just want yo just social justice work
even in the jim crow south right when
they had segregation which
you admit is racist right jim crow south
i don't know what that is
you need a little bit of critical race
there in your life then
but uh yeah critical race theory
obviously the the complex legal theory
that you know no kids are learning about
but like once you identify what it is
you can talk about that and
um one of the things that they used to
do in the jim crow south and this
happened in the north as well obviously
through redlining but one of the things
they used to do in the south is um they
would never expressly say black people
are not allowed to vote in certain areas
in order to avoid the uh the the
scrutiny uh from you know these uh
progressive folk these commies so what
they would do is uh they would institute
grandfather laws and what that means is
if your grandfather was not allowed to
vote
then you would be subjected to a test
like these these voter tests or or you'd
be subjected to a poll tax for example
in order to be able to vote so that way
they didn't say black people can't vote
they just simply stated if your
grandfather who was a slave could not
vote then you can't vote without these
additional restrictions to stop you from
what's wrong with having you know
what's wrong with showing an id at the
poll we just want to make sure that the
people that vote are the people they say
they vote if you if you think that's a
problem then you cheating
so a lot of countries already have voter
id laws but the main difference between
those countries and ours is that it is
incredibly exceptionally difficult you
hate the dmv i suspect you don't want to
go there obviously i hate the deal
yeah it's communist
yeah it's under funding next thing
you're going to tell me i need a license
to use my damn toaster
[Music]
yeah that's right
it's coming so what's racist about that
so voter id laws because of how
inaccessible dmvs are especially if
you're working every single day
uh are are created so that um you know
they're oftentimes even created in areas
where there's no dmvs in poor
neighborhoods uh in predominantly black
and black and white neighborhoods
um they're they're created as a way to
ensure that less people vote right it's
yet another problem it's it's uh it's
portrayed as a solution to a
non-existent issue what i mean by that
is there have been numerous studies
conducted on this and list that he's
conducted on this by republican think
tanks
right wing think tanks liberal think
tanks bipartisan commissions have been
launched george w bush had a commission
on this donald trump had a commission on
this and every single investigation has
concluded that voter fraud is not
happening voter fraud happens at such
marginal levels that it will never be
able to move the needle on an election
or an electoral outcome so
it's basically another way to stop
people from voting in a country where
literally the plurality doesn't even
vote to begin with if anything we should
be making it easier for people to vote
um so that you know poor people have a
harder time going out and voting and
don't end up voting at all
that's all it is
one of the i'm a great character here
one of the best and easiest ways i've
understand and explained systemic racism
and it's more like a cl a class this
thing too
but basically property taxes fund local
schools boom
done
rich communities get better education
they make more money
uh they have more generational wealth
poor poor communities you know and and
and communities of uh minor majority
minorities are gonna have worse
education as a result less funding and
therefore you know
less accumulation of wealth and you and
you
multiply that
uh through generations yeah it just gets
worse never catch up and of course that
is uh
and one way to effectively shut people
out of that even in the north was
through redlining
what re ain't no heard no damn red line
the only red line i believe in is live
alongside white people in white
neighborhoods even if they had the money
to do so i think white should stick to
whites and blacks to should stick to
black what's racist about that that's
quite definitionally it is racist okay
commie it's literally segregation you
know what you're advocating for
yeah well they want to stay with
themselves and we want to stick with
ourselves we ain't no problem with that
no there is there is definitely
especially when people consensually want
to live alongside one another that is
there is a problem with
me pushing back against that
okay
well if you ask me why people are the
most discriminated against in today's
society you look at me i can't even
express myself i can't even say the n
word no more yeah that's outrageous good
thing
it's outrageous it's it's an affront on
my freedoms so
um this is a really this is a really
common one too obviously uh white people
are discriminated against certainly but
not on the virtue of being white
white people can be oppressed in today's
society and often are as a consequence
of being poor
now
race in that situation
is uh plays another role on top of class
this isn't the mean that like obviously
oprah winfrey as a black woman is in a
worse position overall than someone like
yourself uh uncle hank uh you know
living in a trailer
uh she is in a better situation she's
more privileged than you from a class
position right
but um
but that actually only plays out that
discrimination only plays out for white
people at least on the basis of class
never on the basis of race because
white people have never been
discriminated against
simply because they're white on the
virtue of the color of their well
actually
i can't say a damn thing these days i
tell you what the woke army out there i
can't say a damn thing i can't share my
opinion they say you're white you're a
man you're straight have i offended you
today
you know i can't even say a damn thing
because i'm quiet
um
i think
i don't know how to respond come on now
bud you know i'm right yeah
you're owning me dude
yeah you know how i'm why when you're
when you're i'm white and
when you're accustomed to a lifetime of
privilege equality feels like oppression
uh
not being able to put down black people
on the virtue of the color of their skin
is not actually oppressing you okay it's
just allowing other black people to
thrive alongside yourself
um they have the exact same goals that
we do okay black people have the same
goals that we uh in the
hype community do okay everyone just
wants uh to put a meal on their table to
have a roof over their own heads
and uh and and the average black person
has the exact same issues and the exact
same goals that the average white person
has
all of those things they want safety or
security there's more crime in black
neighborhoods now if i don't want to
live near black people why shouldn't i
be able to say that they bring the crime
they bring the drugs and i just want
them part of that thing white people and
black people consume drugs at a similar
rate especially when it comes to
marijuana for example except black
people are heavily persecuted and
prosecuted for the same exact defenses
and get way longer prison sentences
because the criminal justice system is
is absolutely uh heavily geared towards
uh further oppressing black people well
i smoke a little meth but i never do
ain't no do no crime yes exactly well
that is that is a crime
right well i guess technically that is a
crime but it's my freedom to do meth all
right now send me down there
you a rab
i thought i was white too and this is
yours
this man's an a-rab how do you get at
this dinner table yeah
they brought me over i'm getting sick of
this caring i hear people talk about
them karen's man
them karen's that's just a racist term
for a white woman it's oppressive and
it's anti-white and i won't have it
so
karen is like cracker okay there's a
difference between being able to say
cracker and uh saying the n-word right
you literally can't say it you just say
the n-word um why don't you call it the
k word then karen's offensive to me
i don't ever want to hear that word
again karen this triggers me by the way
that's the
fork is trembling that's a that's one of
the beautiful parts about this where
it's like um the very same people that
argue in the same breath that they
should be able to say the n-word will
then turn around and show how triggered
and and upset they are and it's like
why are you so true how dare you call me
a carrot yeah my wife got called a
carrying the other day yeah
your wife left you so
that's why we're here i miss her
that's why i drink
yeah um
karen is just another way for like
people who are have historically been
marginalized to blow off steam it's it's
inconsequential it's not tacked along
with like any sort of significant
history of
of of uh marginalization have women been
marginalized throughout the society of
course they absolutely but not on the
basis of being white women uh again
especially when they are pitted against
uh black folk so it just means you're
behaving like a karen there's just a
hordes of people walking around cameras
filming white women
waiting for white women to have an
explosion it ain't right i'll tell you
what in a lot of instances it's actually
the cairns themselves that are filming
themselves because they think that what
they're doing is righteous but you know
it turns out it's not so
well i'll tell you the other problem i'm
having these days man
talking about genders talk about two
genders talk about trans whatever that
is you know there's two genders that's
it
i don't know what all the z's and x y z
about [ __ ] i'm talking about there's
a penis and a vagina you know that's
biology
so
um
gender is a social construct it's
basically like what you put on top of
what most people consider now to be
biological gender but even that is not
um
even that's not a binary because they're
intersex people uh and and obviously
gender is uh super fluid it's just how
you express yourself and how you
identify yourself i went never letting
one of them trans in a bathroom with my
kid
how would you know that when someone is
trans what are you going to do look at
their penis vagina yeah like
me i ain't no gay pull up someone like
buck angel for example like if you pull
up buck angel uh a photo of buck angel
look him up he sounds like a tough dude
i like this bucket yeah he is a tough
dude that's right who's this buck angel
we talk there you go now that's a cool
dude i like to get a beer with him maybe
yeah so pass around the map if tyra is
not if gender is not a social construct
wait you tell
that's a man how would you point out
this person in a crowd if you want to
get your bag
and that's the man what's your problem
with buck angel exactly well there's no
problem with buck angel buck angel does
happen to be
a trans woman
yeah and that man of trance that's the
devil's work i ain't let no man in the
bathroom like that so if you would want
you would want this big burly man to be
peeing in the women's restroom then yeah
we
hell yeah you would want this big burly
man to be peeing in the women's
restaurant that man should be you that
man should be playing out in the woods
you ain't got no place in no battle
that's ultimately what it comes down to
is that most transphobic people just
want trans people to not exist yes all
right and that is an issue so i say you
know let people pee wherever the [ __ ]
they want to and if the uh common
retort is like oh they're doing it to
like do indecent sexual acts or or
anything like that well that's still
illegal you know you can't it's not
legal magically when you're a trans
person what happened
what happens
if i'm peeing next to this buck angel
there
and i start to feel a certain type of
way then you know it's a beautiful
expression of your love what do i do
with that you should engage in it
would probably treat you better than
brenda did that scares me hessen yeah
hussein pecker yeah that's right i don't
like this buck angel he makes me uncomfy
get that off my screen damn it yeah he's
i mean he scares me
[Music]
you would never point to book and be
like can you get my bag
uh from next to her like you would never
use the her she her gender pronouns when
you're when you're referencing black
angel wow i just feel like if someone
asked me to tell say their damn pronoun
if that's there's a man who wants me to
call her or she it just ain't happening
now having said that passability is not
the only metric for uh whether or not
you should respect someone's pronouns or
their gender identity or their gender
expression um i am of the mindset that
you should just be polite to people if
if someone tells you their name is you
know uh bojangles you don't say no
your name is not bojangles your name is
actually uh you know henry no it's
bojangles so just uh you know that
sounds like treat people uh with
kindness and respect i think i'll tell
you what man all these people worried
about kovitz shutting down the damn
government shutting down our schools
this cover ain't nothing but just the
flu man it's crazy obviously it's not
just the flu the flu the common flu is
still pretty deadly kills around thirty
thousand to forty thousand people a year
yeah we shut down the government for the
damn flu every year well don't do that
because uh you know that would that
would be a real big economic stressor
however covet on the other hand has
killed almost 800 000 people here in the
united states since it started so man
you believe that [ __ ] i i do why do i
believe that well because there's uh
you know around 800 to a million
additional deaths that occurred
throughout covid i tell you they mark
anything as covert these days people be
dying a heart attacks and
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and they just go
covered because they get
you know even if that was the case right
then uh and this is one way to analyze
uh the rate of deaths in any given time
is by looking at prior years right
so what would happen is if that was the
case then you would have a similar
number of deaths that are occurring
uh in 2020 and in 2021
but that is not what has happened we've
had
additional deaths if you look at the cdc
data that's readily available
yeah you believe that that will work
i do believe this dr falchi
uh i i managed himself i mean i'm not
like a super big fan of dr fauci myself
but it doesn't matter i believe in the
science
sciences and you trust the cdc i i do
trust the the
yes the disease control is your problem
i don't trust the city i don't trust no
government agency okay um well that's
categorically false it's impossible for
you to survive in society without
trusting any government agencies i don't
trust nobody but my own two hands except
for facebook and buck angel over there
who i can't stop thinking about
i tell you what though man
i don't know i ain't getting the vaccine
because my immune system's strong i
ain't been sick in five years your
immune system is not strong you are uh i
mean not you in particular what do you
mean my immune system son i'm just
saying first of all you literally had a
problem with your
you talked about an allergic reaction
not that long ago yeah well that means
my immune system is strong it reacted
right is the virus coming out
of your body but
um hassan i'm not
the character didn't have a uh okay well
i was i was imagining like a like a way
fatter diabetic uncle yeah 50 of
americans have uh or more than that
actually six percent of americans have a
coleman you're just calling me fat and
unhealthy now no no which is true i'm
not saying that
i'm just saying i don't need no damn
vaccine i ain't been sick in years
um
so i don't trust it even if you have a
fine immune system uh covet can still be
very deadly as a matter of fact uh for
the past two months in well in september
and october uh covid was the number one
uh reason for fatalities in the united
states of america for men over the age
of uh 30 uh 35 i think or no 45
so
that's it's still incredibly deadly uh
depending on who you're talking to that
person is probably going to be over the
age of 45
and uh it it is still a super
super deadly
issue
if you're not vaccinated because guess
what at the end of the day you can look
at all of these numbers you can look at
the numbers uh and and claim like oh
well people that don't have the vaccine
are still getting covered like what what
difference does it make well that's
right they're not going to have the damn
virus so what's the point they're not
going to the hospitals y'all said i
would have immunity and now you're
saying i can catch the virus that won't
you make sense
well that's fine that's normal uh
vaccine normal
yes vaccines don't uh don't always
eradicate
the likelihood of you getting uh the
disease especially when it's something
like covid
uh it's not happening in this case and
people have never said that it would 100
percent
uh stop you from getting covered well
what's right if i catch covid
it just stops you from going to the
hospital it's not going to the hospital
i ain't going no hospital ain't got
health insurance know how exactly i
can't afford that [ __ ] it's not a bad
it's it's i'm just going to die you
definitely need to buy that's why you
definitely need the vaccine because it's
free
well
i just catch covet anyway and the
natural immunity is more effective than
the damn covert anyway so i don't need
that [ __ ] it's not true natural immunity
is not more effective than covet
especially because the data is
incredibly inconsistent with natural
immunity your body might not have the
uh your body might not have developed
enough antibodies and as a matter of
fact i believe in the latest studies
conducted it was like 30 percent of
people uh create the necessary amount of
antibodies to have like natural immunity
over an extended period of time
whereas with the vaccine at least in the
first six month window when you get both
shots you are still reliably covered
from the worst aspects of man i didn't
understand a word you just said boy
vaccines are good for you they're better
than natural immunity one because you
don't get coveted in the process
okay when you get the vaccine
and you don't have to deal with like
getting coveted which can be deadly and
is in a lot of instances
um but also on top of that
uh vaccines offer more reliable and
long-term coverage i just don't trust
this new vaccine they enter they
they alter in my perfect beautiful
genome they're not doing that that's not
a real thing the mrna vaccine technology
has been around for quite a long time
since 1985 they've been working on it
but there's also the johnson and johnson
vaccine which is yeah but that's
giving them strokes to people also not
true the johnson johnson vaccine was
stopped for a brief moment when exactly
when the fda wanted to ensure that it
was as safe as possible and it was safe
it was safe enough for the fda to
restart that [ __ ]
i'll tell you what i will take get some
of that damn ivermectin it been one a
damn nobel peace prize it's one of the
hell yeah causing peace in this planet
what yeah nobody and i'll tell you what
else
lobotomies also got a nobel prize but
you know they're they're discontinued as
a medical practice uh and as far as
ivermectin goes yes it is a dewormer it
is most commonly used on livestock and
animals but uh covet is not a worm uh
the testing done on ivermectin uh showed
no conclusive reliability
said he said he had this guy brett
weinstein on there he said man if we all
just took ivermectin this virus begone
and i'll tell you what it's just a big
conspiracy
these damn big vaccine making so much
money selling this [ __ ] we don't need no
vaccine we just need our company
well ivermectin is also made by a big
pharmaceutical corporation it's made by
merck
who's that merck is a big pharma
corporation very similar to pfizer
and they are the ones who make
ivermectin and even surprisingly they
were the ones who were first out of the
gates to say ivermectin is not a
reliable cure for covet is not a
reliable treatment for covet we will
keep monitoring today though because
they stand to gain the most out of this
right they said that they would keep
monitoring the data to see if there was
actually any sort of treatment because
everybody ultimately wants to get away
from this [ __ ]
uh you know
from this pandemic business nobody wants
to stay indoors trapped in homes people
want to go back to
to their normal lives i personally hate
going to the gym and wearing a mask i
want to never wear a mask
you wear a mask you [ __ ] you shape
you wear that face diaper on your face
boy even vouchy himself say it don't do
nothing then he changes mine he say it
do something man that felt you can't
keep one thing straight well mask
wearing especially paired up with social
distancing is a very effective way at
combating this issue
well if it didn't do [ __ ] then we would
have seen uh similar rates of covet in
countries that actually had some serious
uh protocols like social distancing
isolating quarantining and also mass
squaring in public uh like china
uh south korea singapore
character you can't keep it straight you
go you gotta wear the mask
says you gotta not wear the mask then he
says you gotta wear the mask inside he
says you gotta wear the mask inside now
we need a booster shot this man is full
of lies and he's satan himself well
originally people thought the earth was
flat or at least some people thought the
earth was flat and then we found out
that that was not the earth isn't flat
no
what did you say and get this devil out
my house and that's how science works
where you get new data and you change
your mind right like
when you learn yeah well the earth is 6
000 years old and you ain't changing my
mind on that okay well okay
so you're telling me
he changed the data as the science
changed no that new data came out um
well specifically in the case of fouchy
with masks
i do agree that like there was some
[ __ ] going on there originally i
think like the part of the reason why
they didn't want uh people to go out and
like you know bum rush masks because of
our shitty supplies they lied to us was
yeah and and you know that is really
terrifying how can i even really scare
you
the man lied to me
i can never trust him again but the
reason why they originally said that was
because they wanted to make sure that
all of the healthcare professionals
people that desperately needed uh ppe
protective gear at a time in the
beginning of the covet uh pandemic
would get that so that they wouldn't uh
run into shortages
just tell me one thing do i need to keep
sending death threats to his kids or not
definitely don't do that okay very
illegal because i'm on a facebook group
called
harass fauci that's and we send
spam death threats to his kids
and to his wife it's a good time for us
boy
that's my favorite time of the week me
and the boys get together i have a few
whiskeys a couple birds and we sent
death threats and even dick pics i'll be
honest with you i think i think what you
should that's highly illegal you're
sending your own nothing legally
america it's that's uh you're exposing
yourself to minors
so that's that's definitely why his kids
ain't no miners boy that man like 90
years old okay well then you know you're
still sending uh your your [ __ ] too yeah
it's america it's freedom it's my
freedom to send my penis you know
freedom whatever i want boy your
freedoms stop when other people's
freedoms begin i think there's like a
barrier
and you sound like isis well you
wouldn't want okay would you want isis
to send you dick pics all day i'll come
for them they send me [ __ ] yeah that's
what i'm saying they could terrorize
your mailbox with dick pics all day
every day he wouldn't like that right
that's scary yeah don't do anything that
you know you wouldn't want done to you
um
i think that's a pretty healthy attitude
well what you should you should find new
hobbies i think
i'll work on that maybe i'll start
throwing [ __ ] from the overpass that was
fun back when i was doing that
definitely that's also illegal highly
illegal you sound a lot like you
definitely fun at all man yeah you sound
a lot like antifa to me that's a man
that ain't no [ __ ] oh man this guy no
[ __ ] fun yo let me tell you man i got
some kids about in
middle school these kids and they coming
out into school they say you ain't no
way no masking school boy you kids ain't
coming here i say damn
my kids ain't getting no educate my kids
[ __ ] go to school i ain't got tom watch
their dumb beat ass
so
uh
yeah no it's you know they should go to
school your kids they they gotta wear
the mask and i say ain't no wear goddamn
mask on their face they got to see them
smile they got to see the teachers got
to see them smile
you don't can't see no face ain't no
damn education i'll tell you just
control me there's there is a dress code
at schools too your kids can't really
wear whatever they want to and masks are
a public safety measure at least for the
time being and
uh once uh all the kids are vaccinated
and have a level of old man
it's all about control
um
technically every kind of regulatory
mechanism is about control it's about
controlling the population so that you
know people that don't want to do things
that would harm others can't do those
things so that we can live in a
civilized society together
obviously all laws are technically
discriminatory towards people that want
to do people that want to break those
laws like for example let's say someone
wants to do a murder well the law is
discriminating against them and they
don't want it well not you but i would
never do that other people want to do
murders right my [ __ ] ex-wife i tell
you that [ __ ] gotta come and i'll tell
you what man and you ain't never gonna
find that party boy
margaret has a cove to death brother
oh yeah you could hide anybody in this
day and age but but one cover death
so i tell you though
so it's not a way to control people as
evidenced by the fact that the moment
that uh you know there was a brief
period of time when we started first
getting vaccines and whatnot
we immediately released the the control
mechanisms of wearing masks and whatnot
and and really relaxed on that which
actually led to a spike in covet but but
that's because people just want to go
back to their regular lies no one wants
to like wear masks all the time no one
wants to uh have to socially distance
all the time and the most effective way
of doing that is reaching herd immunity
which is becoming more and more unfair
and they don't hurt you and your friends
we wanted to reach her to muni we just
let this virus go boy
no mass no vaccine we just get over it
like the good old days back into
1920 we had some kind of
flu some spanish flu yeah that was no
spanish flu now
yeah because
you know there were there were control
mechanisms back then as well even though
science was not as advanced and medical
technology was not as advanced back then
as it is now
and then we have the we did not have the
deep understanding that we do of like
how these diseases spread
but uh ultimately
letting it rip
letting the spanish flu rip uh caused
many fatalities even after uh you know
enforcing certain like masked rules and
whatnot during that era as well well
millions and millions of people dying
which we are reaching uh level 9. i'll
tell you what
man if trump if they didn't steal the
election from trump like they did we
won't be even having these problems you
know
man trump won that damn election i never
vote for democrat demon crap
yeah um
no
trump did not win the election
uh
how do you explain them [ __ ] down in
arizona they did that recount boy yeah
i'm telling you they're funny stuff with
their machines yeah uh we had people
voting something right we have one of
the most secure processes because we
still use paper ballots and those are
fairly hard to uh cheat on because
there's no like hacking you just
straight up well my cousin my cousin
down in georgia he used one of them
digital ones ain't no paper ballot in
that and he does not do that
there's still there's still paper
ballots
in america what about in arizona also
paper ballot what about in damn like
florida there's the paper ballots
everywhere around the country florida
the machines got hacked that's what the
president trump said the machines were
hacked by cuban
socialist agents
yeah no that did not happen i i'm afraid
and also trump won florida so
yeah wouldn't that favor him
well
you know what
there's a reason why in georgia for
example when people criticize the
georgia election electoral outcomes even
if it's like someone like marjorie
taylor green doing so she's not you know
she's not criticizing the same ballot
that she was on her election was not uh
you know that is interesting i got to
say because she won yeah it's on the
same team
don't make no kind of sense
i tell you what though man if they were
able to uh cheat their way
into uh electoral victories
why would they create a system where
like uh you know
it hangs in the balance of like
a 50 50 split uh senate why wouldn't
they just uh create a super majority in
the senate so they can pass bills you
know terrifying bills like uh
like health care like expansion i tell
you man you know where i live it's all
trump signs it's trump everyone i know
was trump he's the greatest man that
ever lived ain't no one i even know vote
for damn joe biden well that's normal
you're around like-minded individuals in
a red state for sure
it just does not mean that it's stolen
just like if you go to california if you
go to like west hollywood in california
there's you know biden signing well what
happened in arizona with them recounts
they found that to be
conclusive that that joe biden had won
the election it sounds like we knew the
recount occurred over and over and over
again recounted again spending a lot of
money some of those recounts actually
found more votes for joe biden than
prior
and uh ultimately yes that the the
despite countless uh recounts and
millions of dollars being wasted for
donald trump's very own personal you
know
uh uh
initiative or his personal narrative
he's a good christian man he's not a
good man he's not a good christian man
he's a funny man there ain't nothing
more christian than donald trump he
brings back good christian values i tell
you what boy i mean donald trump is is
definitely he's definitely interesting
charismatic i understand why people
enjoy listening to him drone on about
the tv man
and about liberals but uh i would not
say that he is a good
wholesome honest uh christian person
come on i think other christians also
recognize that they just think that you
know he's a good christian man because
he's like anti-abortion even though he
wasn't originally
well he loves his family
yeah he has sex with his own daughter he
only loves everyone we love that around
here
the only person that donald trump loves
in his family is ivanka that's why you
don't ever hear about tiffany
who's tiffany i've never heard of her
that's trump's other daughter what and
he absolutely pretty like ivanka she got
big titties like ivanka i'm not going to
say anything about that but
ultimately uh you know he he did
i guess i don't know
[Music]
i think she got some big ones there but
you know i like that
because i'm straight yeah yeah and not
fantasizing ain't no gay man not
fantasizing about buck angel
that buck angel got good biceps i'll
tell you okay i'll tell you what though
give me give me more
what else you got settle down hussain
i'm just i'm excited
this affirmative action this force
diversities a bunch of [ __ ] because
the best man should get the job
you going down these universities it's
all a bunch of jews and chinese all this
[ __ ] you ain't seen no why people left
there boy
literally untrue as a matter of fact um
the real affirmative action that no one
actually talks about is legacy
admissions you don't want them rich boys
legacy admissions you want them rich
city boys than buy coastal elites
getting into colleges even though don't
have them yeah exactly like jared
kushner whose dad paid for a new wing in
the library i don't like that jew boy oh
oh geez okay well you know well he he is
a
legacy admission there was a new study
that actually was conducted that showed
that 43 of harvard's uh white uh student
body
uh actually was uh
not qualified for uh by the same metrics
they got in because they got
scholarships they were on a dean's list
specifically uh or
um
or they were legacy admissions or
children of the stude of the staff well
what about like i got this cousin's
second cousin's best friend's wife's
child's uh you know
name is
jim bogg mm-hmm
jimmy he applied to harvard university
he ain't getting no he didn't get uh
admission but yeah he's a prisoner
the black boy across the street did he
got the same grace the black boy got
into harvard how you explain that eh
racism because uh a lot of these college
campuses want to maintain uh a a
diverse student body which they believe
fosters a better educational environment
which is understandable and also the
applications aren't strictly on like
scholastic aptitude
but also about like your life
experiences
your your essays ultimately college the
the college application process is like
totally [ __ ] distorted and greatly
benefits wealthy people um especially if
they have legacy admissions like they
have a parent or whatnot that has
already gone into school there um and
affirmative action is simply just a
band-aid solution
it's not uh it's not the right way to go
about it but it's unfortunately the best
we got at the moment it sounds samia
like the poor whites
getting the worst side of the stick
there it seems like the poor whites are
the damn most hated group most
most race most racist against group in
the country that's simply not true um
but uh yes poor white people do get the
short end of the stake from a class
position because america is
categorically opposed to a classist
analysis
uh in the in the same way that you know
uh we don't we don't approach uh
poor white people in a similar capacity
that we do to
at least some uh some racist injustices
which i uh think we should we should
look at
and solve issues about material issues
from a class point of view as well i'm
right but ultimately remember if
whenever there is a poor white kid
there's also a poor black kid right next
door and he has it worse off in that
poor white kid because they're they're
also black on top of it
so it's a compounding factor in their
discrimination and oppression
i tell you what man we wouldn't be
having none of those problems if young
people weren't so damn lazy
productivity is much much much higher
now than it has ever been because of
technology people are working 24 7. as a
matter of fact in portugal and in france
they implemented laws that your boss
literally can't
force you to work after 5 pm
these are really good initiatives that
protect workers
and yet the real issue is despite our
gigantic increase in productivity our
wages have remained stagnant um back in
the day you could work at the factory or
the coal mine or wherever the [ __ ]
you're working with jim bob and you'd be
able to make enough pay you had unions
that protected you that had your back
and you could go home and you could buy
a house you can't you know you man i
when i was younger
your age hussain
i buy me
a house a car my wife don't even work me
and i tell you what these kids they just
don't want to work i talk to them they
don't want to work we got labor
shortages people just don't want to work
they lazy um the economy is nearly
recovered back to the pre-pandemic
levels but
there's still a shortage of four million
jobs according to the latest jobs report
but the main problem in the service
sector in the service industry is that
uh
the the wages are not
improving to get to a level where uh
people want to work
in such uh horrible conditions
and i i believe that businesses whether
big or small should pay their workers a
living wage a better wage i tell you
what my cousin owned a restaurant he had
to pay his workers another dollar an
hour he'd go bankrupt he won't be
existing that's not even true that's
that is true
if that was the case then you know
mcdonald's for example in a place like
denmark would not be able to pay 22
dollars an hour to their employees a lot
of these big businesses absolutely have
enough money and even small businesses
have enough money you just have to
restructure your profit margins and
maybe make a
get a little bit of a pay cut
uh man you don't understand economics
you pay people more the prices go up
eight no difference well the prices if
that was the case again then a big mac
in denmark would be a hundred dollars
when it is uh simply like 30 cents or 40
cents more expensive than a big mac here
um so that's not even true
um
um but you some kind of when you some
kind of econ i missed no not at all
yeah i don't i don't believe in that uh
that voodoo
well i tell you this world would be
way better off if we weren't buying into
this global warming hoax
we wasting so much money on these damn
windmills killing birds we're not we
should be um we we give billions and
billions of dollars in subsidies to
every sector from agriculture all the
way to energy
and uh 85 of the energy extraction
subsidies go to the fossil fuel industry
that's the reason why fracking and uh
numerous other ways of
of like generating energy
uh are still seen as like viable
solutions are still seen as like
profitable sectors without the
government actually funding those uh
businesses and funding those sectors
they would no longer be profitable what
i simply suggest is moving that dial
back to the green energy sector which
has hundreds of thousands of new job
openings it's a growing sector rather
than a
rather
man like the earthquake warms up it
cools how we even know that the man got
anything to do with this [ __ ] well um
the
don't ask me i mean if you don't believe
me believe exxon
whose internal data showed all the way
back in 1985 that global warming was
happening because of uh
their their carbon footprint and their
carbon emissions uh so but instead of uh
immediately informing the proper
authorities they started creating a
system in which uh people like you would
turn around and believe their lies that
they were not actually uh playing a
significant role in in uh anthropogenic
climate change
i don't know man you've been here last
winter
it's cold as hell man yeah we're done
global warming
yeah climate change manifests in
different ways it's not just about the
world of the world warming okay even
though temperatures are rising
uh but it's also about uh erratic
weather conditions things that normally
uh would be like once in a lifetime
tornadoes hurricanes uh happening uh way
way way more frequently uh that's why we
have uh these extreme weather conditions
happen so much more frequently now which
is also awful for our infrastructure
another thing that we need to do is is
basically
you know
shore up our defenses
against
uh you know hurricanes and whatnot i
don't think you really
got all that but i'll tell you what man
the moon that shit's not it that's a
government conspiracy
how do you know the moon really exists
uh that i can't give you any information
have you been to the moon who's saying i
have not but i haven't been to somalia
either but i know it exists i don't
have you been to
i ain't been outside this town boy you
know that do you think nebraska exists
ain't not been no nebraska do you think
donald trump exists you've never seen oh
yeah donald trump is real as again i've
never seen him in person jfk junior is
coming back you wait okay i'll tell you
one other thing man that joe biden
he ain't no kind of president he
he he defiled our good troops out there
in afghanistan
what a mess
what a coward
yeah um joe biden was simply acting uh
on donald trump's negotiations donald
trump was the one who uh donald trump's
administration was the one who not only
released uh barabar the number one you
know
barabar
um he is uh the leader of the taliban
the number one guy in the taliban he
released him out of the pakistani prison
that he was in to negotiate with him and
totally sidelined the afghan government
that they had installed as a puppet
state that was already very unpopular
and the uh conditional evacuation was
always going to be troublesome
no matter which way you put it but
ultimately 75 percent of the country uh
still considers
evacuating afghanistan and stopping our
endless wars there at the very least to
be a good thing so i think joe biden did
the right thing except you know the
media including those dirty liberals at
msnbc and cnn attacked him for doing the
right thing the right thing that donald
trump also wanted to do which was pull
out of afghanistan
so um if you're upset at the way joe
biden botched quote-unquote afghanistan
then you're basically criticizing the
supreme leader donald trump because
those were his terms that he had
negotiated with the taliban all right
you know what who's saying i won't talk
no more with you just eat your damn
mashed potatoes and shut up okay
remember it's all about uh thoroughly
i mean i i was i was much nicer but um
you know because you can make leeway in
certain circumstances one of the things
you can do is find common ground
uh and uh but if if the person is just
like totally belligerent and delusional
then you could just like
ritualistically humiliate them and
that'll make you feel good and that'll
make them feel bad
[Music]
debate is about you feeling good and
then feeling bad 100 yeah it's about
it's literally about like making them
look like
buffoons all right well
we gotta wrap it up i hope you guys
thanksgiving is better than the one that
just played out here
but uh regardless happy thanksgiving
we're going to war
yep if it goes south you can come to our
underground nuclear bunker
uh we'll be having a safe haven for the
liberals yeah we'll be we'll be
defending we'll be defending ourselves
from the conservatives
all righty guys take care
bye bye
[Music]